who was on the new album
um I got G herbo on there I got Jadakiss
I got burner I got Dave East big burns
on the album big burns on the album man
I'm trying to get him to shoot this
running gun you know cause burn like to
shoot running gun videos you gotta go to
the Bay man and now he's like big
billionaire burn so he's by the way he's
been big billionaire bro for sure like
no he's on like Forbes list like right
now now everyone knows he's telling it I
knew this [__] I was telling my homies
like a while ago but um I shot a run and
Gun on his album before where we just
you know ran around and shot the video
but now I'm I'm trying to do one with
him where I just follow him for two days
see like the life of burning
incorporated into the video but yeah
he's on there um man I'm gonna forget
people Sada James this incredible artist
named Sada James you'll be hearing of a
uh
super talented I forget who else
G herbo you said that yeah me you yeah I
feel like you and Berner because Berner
likes to do collab albums with people
yeah he's like you know he's done now
I'd love to collab albums with people I
feel like it'd be kind of hard if you
and Bernadette like a whole little
[__] six or seven pieces that'd be
hard I actually get fans that come to my
shows like in in Chicago and different
places and they'll be like yo I met you
through burn a lot of Mexican guys
the Mexicans love burning for sure a lot
of Mexican fans I got through on burning
so what was did he reach out to you
um I got a I got a mutual acquaintance
with him um my man taba like a like an
OG from my city and somehow they linked
me with him but yeah it was all love and
then he was like come get on my album
you know I came to his session
I had to beat right there I wrote my
[__] right there it's Gotta feel dope
man because like you are not a new
artist by any means like it's like I'm
not a new artist but I'm a brand new
artist but we've told the story before
like I met you at South by Southwest in
like 2000 yeah I remember I was walking
home 14 probably I was walking home in
the streets drunk nobody here at the
same Hotel
no I think you yeah yeah you was in the
line for something we're we're at like a
hotel bar or something it was like it
was like by the valet or the bar at the
uh that hotel that's like I remember but
I can remember walking down Sixth Street
right lost yeah I remember walking down
Sixth Street and nobody knowing me you
know a lot of last time like yeah a lot
of less tattoos but just nobody knew me
anyway
now they recognize me through the mass
I'll be having a shasty mess like this
one you put hands in my pockets [__]
like this maybe like Millies and be like
how bro but um yeah I remember I
remember seeing you because I was
walking down 6th Street nobody knows I
said that's bootleg cab I forget even
where I knew you from but you were doing
I mean I was kind of like back then I
was like on the blogs a lot with my
interviews and [__] yeah yeah they're
like two dope boy days yeah that's why I
love seeing your [__] go up because even
at the time to me you were like popping
right you know what I mean so now you
really popping
um but it's got to feel good to be on
such a long
journey of being a by taking this
Rapture serious to end up doing you know
records with some Legends and then
obviously
Lincoln with Snoop Dogg and you know
what I'm saying like there's like I feel
like you've had so many moments in the
last couple of years where like
you know do you feel like
validated I know you've always known
yeah but like to kind of get the peers
to kind of give you that cosign that's
got to mean a lot man yeah I picked up a
lot of cosine like I picked up a lot of
co-signs in rap
but then like I got cosigned by the
money hmm that's what that's the one
thing like I wasn't turning the profit
from this [__] yeah you were kind of
doing it I was doing it just getting by
like I would make money I've been
getting paid for features for 12 13
years right you know what I mean would
that would you say that was kind of more
the bread and the butter like I could
get features I I'm doing my shows to get
hot it wasn't no real money right you
know
and the second I did get a little real
money I just put more back into myself
the pandemic did it for me for real but
like I would say like yeah the
validation from you know whether it's
like you know I'm signing a kiss and I'm
like Snoop is like a big supporter of
mine and um just all these guys in the
game you know and and so so it's that
but then it's
I see it reflecting in my bank account
like I got accountants now and [__] and
I'll be like damn like I really made it
like I shot a tear on a plane one time
like for real like I just had a crazy
day and I just shed a tear like I
couldn't believe it like because I was
really thinking I can't believe that I
was dumb enough to believe in this [__]
that I made happen like yeah I mean but
it's hard for some sacrifice yeah it's
hard work and sacrifice and I feel like
sometimes you just got to be dumb enough
to believe you know if that makes sense
yeah that's the real [__] I mean you had
a lot of I feel like you had a lot of
like like uh uphill battles to fight
being the white dude rapping about
Street [__] yo bro it's almost
impossible it's like an uphill battle on
roller skates when you think about it
like because I'm actually doing
something that's never been done correct
because you know we know all the
different type of rappers that came
through hip-hop
and there's never been a white rapper
with the street content they run around
with jewelry on really in the trenches
really moving around really co-signed by
the right people [__] right it just
hasn't happened correct ever ever ever